[Musique]
marie-aude réel nous annonce un tweet
soleil aujourd'hui de quoi satisfaire
les amateurs de jardinage qui risque de
prendre d'assaut les centres de
jardinage horticulture pendant le long
week-end la fête des patriotes
bah c'est devenu une tradition vraiment
puis avec moi albert mondor
horticulteurs auteur de plusieurs
ouvrages sur l'horticulture
environnementale l'agriculture urbaine
bonjour albert bonjour fait plaisir à
gué du monde d'être là ce matin c'est
mon plaisir à moi aussi plus trop là est
ce que c'est la bonne fin de semaine
pour planter cette année avec le
printemps qu'on a eus bois il faut bien
des gestes ce serait le moment de
planter puis arrête on a un peu plus le
dessus du mauvais temps de la grisaille
alors je pense qu'il est grand temps de
se mettre au jardinage ne vous rêverez
n'est pas c'est le temps de planter la
plupart des légumes sauf les légumes
tropicaux
alors les légumes qui demande beaucoup
de chaleur l'aubergine le poivron la
tomate
on peut peut-être attendre un peu encore
jusqu'à la toute fin de mai peut-être
même début juin selon les régions
par contre tous les légumes de climat
frais lichens lille et tuent les
épinards les bocks torreilles
la plupart des fines herbes aussi mise à
part le basilic le qui demande beaucoup
de chaleur mais on peut planter le temps
on peut planter la série y est on peut
planter le perçu sans problème
absolument tous les légumes racines le
carottes les pommes de terre s'il tente
ou médecin tu n'y a pas de risque avec
le gel au sol parfois qu'on peut avoir
est ce que c'est vous dit le même
conseil pour pour l'échelle du québec
par exemple est absolument lequel par
exemple est une plante qui résistent
très liée au froid ça peut résister à
des températures de - 10 le moins 12
degrés celsius il peut être ça mais où
planter dès le mois d'avril
on n'a pas à attendre la toute fin mais
le pot planter c'est une plante qui
aiment la fraîcheur il peut neiger sur
lequel il va très bien ça remet pas de
problème mais la condition cependant si
ces plaintes ont été cultivées sont
achètent des plans à pau ce qu'ils ont
été cultivés dans une cela il faut les
acclimater c'est important de ne pas
leur donner trop grand choc donc on les
sort quelques heures on les rentrées au
bout de deux ou trois jours de cette
gymnastique l'on peut finalement les
mettre en travers l'oeuvre me l'apprenez
je savais pas qu'on devait faire ça donc
on les sort à l'extérieur on les
rentrées fois bonjour
pendant quelques heures par jour on les
laisse à l'extérieur les rendre pour la
nuit pour les ressors de là mais un peu
plus longtemps
voilà comme ça sert à quelque chose avec
les fleurs oui c'est exactement serons
prêts si certaines classes sont très
résistantes au froid on pense notamment
aux
souci les pense également ceux des
plantes résistantes de géranium à les
femmes le pélargonium à côté c'est le
vrai terme c'est vrai le vrai nom de ces
plâtres ceux des plantes extrêmement
résistant donc on peut se permettre de
planter dès maintenant il faut les
acclimater d'accord vous nous avez
apporté votre tout nouvel ouvrage les
plates-bandes gourmande ces plans là
dedans que vous vous spécialisez depuis
des années les fameux jardins elle
comestible
oui j'ai toujours adoré les plantes
comestibles j'en ai toujours cultivé
mais parra faisait des gains jardin
potager mais je me suis beaucoup
intéressé pendant plusieurs années
uniquement aux plantes ornementales mail
à cette époque lui en tout cas ce qui me
concerne est révolu maintenant je
m'intéresse c'est ce qui est beau et ce
qui est bon aussi
je considère qu'aujourd'hui devrait être
utilitaires mais devrait aussi être
jolie devrait être bout donc il devrait
nourrir l'esprit nourrir la merci
nourrir le corps est vraiment tendance
est tout à fait en fait c'est plus
qu'une tendance je dirais même qu'il
s'agit carrément d'un mode de vie les
gens ont besoin de retrouver le sens des
aliments l'offre alimentaire l'industrie
agro alimentaire offrent des produits
qui sont pas toujours à la hauteur de
nos attentes ya beaucoup de problèmes
aussi actuellement il ya là à
l'industrie agroalimentaire alors je
pense que les gens ont grand besoin de
retrouver l'essence des aliments ce
noyau de nourriture saine de qualité
qu'ils ont produit quand même le calme
donc ça permet d'éviter le gaspillage on
peut pas respirer et autosuffisant avec
ce genre de jardin lors qu'on fait chez
soi mais à tout le monde peut dépendre
moins justement de la bouffe qu'on
trouve un supermarché donc avec beaucoup
de frais champion répond sur les
aliments exactement veut consommer on se
dit bon ben au moins on sait quels
produits il ya eu sur ce que je mange
mais c'est ça on a le contrôle ce conte
sur ce qu'on mange quand plus baisse
s'est faite à proximité de chez soi
c'est fait à côté donc il ya moins de
transport moins de gaspillage vous savez
qui est un légume sur deux sur la
planète un free sur deux en fait c'est
45 pour ça le vrai chiffre de tous les
légumes et les fruits qui sont jamais
consommé les chefs de file
c'est énorme et ça c'est lié en grande
partie aux transports et entreposage
évidemment chez nous aussi dans les
nourrit fédérateur vont faire beaucoup
de nourriture mais on en apprend
davantage par le transport et parle
l'entreposage donc en faisant de
l'agriculture urbaine en créant des
plates bandes gourmandes ou encore en
jardinant à bochum votre terrasse mais
vous pouvez éviter ce transport est ce
gaspillage et c'est quoi le meilleur
conseil que vous donneriez ce matin pour
commencer une plateforme une plate-bande
gourmande par rapport à l'association
des légumes qu'on peut mettre les uns à
côté des autres par exemple je pense
qu'il faut il faut y aller avec beaucoup
de créativité est imaginatif s'amuser
aussi ne pas pas d'avoir fait de faire
des erreurs
donc on marie les plantes à peu près
tout va avec tout il ya quelques plantes
qui s'associent difficilement on pense
au fenouiller par exemple qui côtoie mal
le poids vol pour avoir fait voix va
réduire sa croissance et son
développement quand il était à proximité
de chez nous tenez vous bien le fenouil
maîtres déclic qu'il émet des vibrations
des ondes sonores des cliquetis que le
poivron peut capter et c'est ce qui fait
qu'il ralentit sa croissance est
vraiment étonnant par contre pour la
plupart des autres végétaux il arrive
bien à se côtoyer et très important par
contre demain des végétaux qui ont des
besoins semblables et on peut marier des
fruits on peut marier des des fleurs
comestibles des légumes des légumes
tropicaux mais vivace aussi comme la
rhubarbe comme des asperges et tout ça
mais les ensembles va lui donner une
place devant avec des plantes
ornementales conseillerais il rien qui
vous empêche de mariée touché avec vos
rosiers qui sont d'ailleurs comestibles
la passion des fleurs des roses se mange
et les fruits aussi très important
cependant d'enlever les semences les
graines des fruits des rosiers qu'on
appelle d'ailleurs des cynorrhodon c'est
le vrai terne
alors il faut enlever les graines parce
qu'elles sont poilus et tenez vous bien
avec ses poils ont fait le poil à
gratter à l'aloe exactement en fait
c'est très urticants d'ailleurs on
appelle les fruits des roses il est
gratuit
et merci beaucoup elle demande alors là
on savent
les râteaux en parler sur le terrain on
va choisir les fleurs et les légumes
qu'on veut planter merci cette semaine